i sold all kinds of uh stuff when i was
a teenager and a kid
since uh preliminary school i always had
like a booth of um
of toyota like of stuff of
nonsense uh unneeded
products that i used to sell people
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm joined today by tut chaney
co-founder and ceo of savannah partners
i thought later in the startup and
innovation arena
toot is the co-founder and ceo of
savannah partners israel's largest
startup ecosystem previously after
selling her first business at the age of
she led the initiation and execution of
massive startup and economic development
projects for organizations such as world
bank group
european commission world economic forum
and others working with more than 5 000
startups across four continents
duchenne welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so honored and humbled and excited
to have you here
i've been waiting for this episode for a
long time i love serona partners and
and i think your journey is incredibly
fascinating and i can't wait to hear
uh the personal side of it so welcome to
my show
thank you so much michael michael how do
you think
in israeli way we would say michael but
do you want to be an american
today or i'll take the israeli way today
uh
in most days especially today especially
with the fact that we might have a siren
in the middle of the episode so
in that case we'll of course go but but
you know that that's a part of the
israeli
i think mindset and we'll still do this
episode on and i can't wait to learn
about
about your journey and you know honestly
tooth i don't even know where to start
besides from the fact that
you're you have the best name in the
world uh strawberry
in hebrew but uh you know from
leadership development specialist at the
television municipality
to head of marketing to being ceo to
being a partner in israel of matchmaker
ventures
uh to being at 365x scale up and then
transitioning to being managing partner
and chief business officer
of serona partners i'm i have to take a
breath to get through
a half of the things that you did who
are you toot
how how does one navigate through so
many different things
and who are you it's a big question and
i would maybe start by telling you the
the professional journey that i've i've
been through and
why entrepreneurship is so much
a connecting line between all of them
and where do they come from
so i started my journey i fell in love
with entrepreneurship when i was about
16.
actually before when i actually realized
that i could um
convince people into doing things and
that was i found it very cool it sounds
like later on
it kind of yeah later on it it
translated to um
the simple fact of you you generate
value and you get money
in return and this this notion this
concept just blew my mind
and i found it fascinating the fact that
you can actually you know get money if
you bring
something to someone that needs that
that that thing
and uh i sold all kinds of uh stuff when
i was a teenager and a kid
since uh preliminary school i always had
like a booth of um
of toyota like of stuff of
nonsense uh unneeded um
products that i used to sell people and
and when i was about 20 i built my first
company
and it was a production company and
we had a theater school and we had a
division that was doing uh
content development and an event
production for children
so we did all the way from birthdays
to big happenings for municipalities
and uh producing uh theater shows for
kids
and we developed few uh tv shows for
kids con
books and and so on and so so forth
and i sold this company and uh
then i went on and i managed marketing
and sales for
a big german corporation that has a
subsidiary in israel
a completely different world by the way
i have to ask
what you just told me that this company
that you that you founded and sold why
start that what was that for the
and for the for the entrepreneurial
spirit or was it because you were
especially
excited about the industry uh it's not a
you know when i looked at your you know
your background that's not a trivial
thing for me to see that you
that that you do right
uh i i actually had a few other
entrepreneurial attempts before i built
this company i had um
actually a tech startup that i was
trying to to build up
back then it was the toolbar um
period yeah and i think before you were
born
it was like the trend was to build two
bars that are
being placed on your browser and the
toolbar making money by
collecting your data and you know making
you do some different types of actions
so i had a startup i started to build i
wanted to
do a toolbar for flatmates to place it
on top of
apartment websites and allow you to find
an
apartment that doesn't only fit the fact
that you smoke or don't smoke and you're
female or male
but also has a flatmate that
characteristically
would fit you and your lifestyle that's
right that was the the startup actually
that doesn't exist
yeah i was about to say today
yeah so that was back in
seven wow six amazing
you know i'm gonna write that down and
one second
i'm adding it to the list yeah
go ahead go ahead if you need startup
ideas i have plenty for you there you go
so i started to do that and then i i
realized that
i don't come from a technology
background even though i am an
electronics engineer
and it's not the same and building
software and building uh
you know electronics and and i decided
to do something i know
from a to z that doesn't have a learning
curve for me and i know precisely how it
looks and where it starts and how it
finishes and i can do it alone
and that's when i started the production
company amazing okay so
i came from this world i was acting and
dancing from a very early age
now i understand and i share a similar
passion how do you get to then
re-enter the tech world but in a very
very dramatic way
because you're not just you know right
running a you know a
business you're you're you're a core
part of the israeli ecosystem today with
serrano partners that has
you know arms and legs in practically
every aspect
of any tech ecosystem especially the
israeli tech ecosystem
how what what happens what to for you to
get there
so saula is basically my um that that's
my dream
if you would ask what what was my vision
when i was a young
uh aspiring entrepreneur sahona was that
so essentially today after building
sauna
and uh and creating this
uh huge ecosystem i
i feel very content because that is
essentially what i've
i've been striving for and the way i got
there
was pretty fun actually um
i was approached by an european
and entrepreneurship organization
kind of community that was organizing
hackathons
for um for students and i became their
ambassador in tel aviv
and i built the hackathon it was 2012
and and it was fantastic apparently it
was the best they ever saw
and and for me it was just another
production i don't care if i produce it
for kids or for
students who wish to be entrepreneurs
which essentially are
permanent kids and
so it was fantastic and they asked me if
i can travel the world and help other
organizers
with their hackathon and voluntarily it
was
a not-for-profit activity so it was
voluntary so i was working
during the weeks in the german company
and the weekends i was traveling the
world turkey
and vienna germany um and i was actually
supporting the local organizers
and that led me to build my second
company after i sold the production
company
and i sold the the production company
and then
this is what led me to to open men's
group
which was what i did before sauna and
men group with
the experience they've had there and
working with entrepreneurs from all over
the world and the the world bank group
and the
big multilateral organizations and
entrepreneurs from all over the world
and different cultures different ages
different startups you know all the way
from ethiopia through japan
to uh eastern europe and then i came
back to israel in 2017
with a vision to build a scale-up
program elaborate on this is that what
led us to
elaborate on this dream i have so much
just to to to stick with you about it i
don't know if 20 minutes would be enough
i am already telling you that it's not
enough and so that's why i'm
i i'm trying to understand you know the
because i like the core because he said
something that i love
this dream that that you had as an
inspiring entrepreneur
define that dream what was that dream to
you
uh i i found that what was the most
um intriguing for me since i was very
young in the entrepreneurial world was
the notion of entrepreneurship
like not a specific industry it was not
entertainment or insurance or finance or
materials or there wasn't a specific
industry that i would i would tell you
wow this this is something i want to
change
but the entrepreneurship environment and
world itself
was something that made gave me enough
you know strength and and vision to say
this is something i want to change
the way the world worked for between
venture capitals and
and startup companies um
the limited paths that were available
for startup companies
up to about seven years ago uh you
didn't have so many options like you
have today
the fact that the the the
um purpose of an israeli startup founder
was to exit this company
and not to build a big company um so
there were
quite a lot of aspects in them in the
ecosystem itself
in this in the landscape of
startupping if you can call it you know
an industry by itself and this industry
is the industry that i'm passionate
about
um so for me this is what i'm changing
you know we have today in sauna we
worked already with over 300 startup
companies
each of them is doing something else and
for me i wouldn't be able to
to be in any of their shoes because i
would be bored too quickly
i'm not passionate about any specific
industry i'm passionate about the
the ecosystem of startuping itself and
how can we make it easier for
entrepreneurs
to build companies and to build big
companies um
and to make this change to bring value
to people
in the world what have you learned on on
an ecosystem level
around this idea of scaling up we we see
this come up all the time
2021 the first quarter of 2021 and now
the second quarter
were ridiculous scale growth uh
but but we're talking also at a time
when you when you were doing this
very intimately where this isn't a part
of the you know the day-by-day
conversations of the israeli ecosystem
what what what what have you learned
about our ecosystem in in terms of
scaling up
so first of all today it is already a
very strong part
of the discussion of the conversation in
israel which is different than what used
to be here
three three four years ago and
there are a few things that are leading
to the change
and that would answer your question one
is
the um the change of
the venture capital financing
they the vcs have changed and from
wanting to exit after four or four or
five years they understand
it is better for them to wait and to
help the company and to stay in the
company to keep their
water there to help the company grow and
to uh to wait for ten years
until they actually exit and they they
built the financial structure that still
allows them
to to do that even if the fund uh the
initial fund has closed
right now they need to do a new one and
so this is one element
and because if you think about what
happened before
many times it came from the from the
fund that said hey
let's sell it right and it came after
five years of inception of the company
so this is one and second is the
uh the
both vision and and
bandwidth of the entrepreneur what do
you mean by that
by bandwidth i mean
often you see second time founders
that are the ones that build the big
company they are not in a rush to sell
because they're already quite okay
financially and
and they now the challenge they want to
tackle is to build the big company
and also by the structure that many
funds have applied to actually buy some
shares from the founders team before
the at the exit time to give them the
the comfort and the confidence to to
keep on pushing
until the company would be big so that's
on the on the bandwidth side
and on the on the confidence side it
envision
to build a big company you need to
change from
from thinking that okay i had this idea
to a product i built this product now
i'm selling this product to someone else
as an exit and i'm going to do a new
thing instead of thinking like that
you start to think by re-developing
the existing product what more can you
can you build on the
on the product you've already developed
and then slowly you become a platform or
you become a multi-product company
and this is the way to build the big
company and to actually you know
scale to sizeable and
organizations like we start to see today
with the unicorns that
that are emerging uh i would say on a
bi-monthly basis
it's insane it's beautiful now it sounds
to me that you you're you're discussing
here
two different things that have to that
have come into play at the same time to
to make for this
big transition on one hand you have the
financial side and the venture capital
side where
the the vcs are more adaptive to this
changing of environment and they're more
supportive
or i would say they're less they're less
pressuring
to do the to do the former way of
exiting
but at the same time you also have
serial entrepreneurs with with multiple
successes behind them that are urging
for something bigger
and you haven't change of mentality that
comes with it of we're not building a
product we're building a company we're
building a brand that
that that is here to stay whether it's
with multiple products or with a product
that keeps iterating did that catch that
correctly
yeah let's think of it this way if if
google would remain just an
um you know a search engine a search
engine
would they be what they are today no if
amazon would stay a book
store would they be what they are today
never
and you can you can think of any big
company that you see today
if they are big and they weren't
acquired it's because they always kept
on developing
right they're definitely actually yeah
this this brings me back to another fun
conversations i had with matanbao
from uh from melio and we were just
talking about this idea that as a
founder sometimes you know he
and he had a decision to make do you
raise you know a serious b or series
c funding essentially what you're saying
to yourself is
at this point i'm no longer acquirable
in the market because the valuation too
high the number of players is too small
enough that that might acquire
not necessarily too familiar but we were
talking more generally that one might
come with that decision
saying either i go big to a public
company
because i'm no longer acquirable in some
way
or i i exit in that way because in that
moment because i might have acquisition
offers
and i'm sure that you know that that is
a phenomenon that that might be
happening right
definitely you know if the company is
good and they're doing
uh well they're likely to receive
acquisition propositions
throughout their their path uh but the
entire ecosystem is maturing you also
see
larger exits than what you you saw
before acquisitions that are
in numbers that would be equivalent to a
serious d right
right no that makes that makes a lot of
sense and on and and
just one more thing also by the way to
balance it on the other side you also
see very early ipos
today like companies that are go public
for like 20 or 30 million dollar value
right and and we're not even discussing
specs and and and that whole a crazy
world
toot i can't believe 20 i didn't even
look at the time that 20 minutes
are going by so fast but i have to ask
for a second
sauna partners uh you're you're looking
at a bunch of different verticals
what what gets you going well what makes
you wake up in the morning
and and have the smile that i'm seeing
here and you telling me that you that
you're fulfilling
the your dream as a young entrepreneur
what what is it about your job
that gets you this excited
and the reason why i fell in love with
entrepreneurship is because
i think um building a factory is built
is better than creating one product why
because when you stop to be there it
still
keeps running so for me if i would
i i'm in a position where i'm helping
entrepreneurs
essentially the um the value and the
impact that i
can generate through those entrepreneurs
is is massive much more than if i would
only have one company i love it given
that i'm doing a good job
wonderful there i have in my mind
a list of 10 more questions that i want
to ask but i do have three
short fun questions for you if you're
ready
all right all right bring it up favorite
subject in school middle school or high
school
okay one of your role models somebody
that inspires you
that's a tough one that's a really tough
one i never had role models
um
my parents were never a role model for
me that that i can tell you
i was very different from from my my
family
maybe design wise
only design wise uh steve jobs work with
with apple was
was phenomenal in my opinion but only
designing i i
i love that and and they obviously we
didn't even mention that you that you
studied in shenzhou engineering design
and art
and so that i understand where that
comes from three words that you would
use to describe yourself
adventurous
um professional
and honest i love that
thank you very very much this was may
we have peace yes thank you take care
[Music]
bye-bye